There's something I'd
like to address tonight.
As you know, a lot of talk show hosts,
they come out and they
tell some monologue jokes
at the top of the show.
Okay, that's fine, but I like to innovate.
Sorry other hosts, that's just me, okay.
Check it out, I have found a great new way
to tell fantastic topical jokes
that adds excitement and sex appeal.
Watch this.
Hey, did you hear this?
Twitter deleted a tweet
from President Trump
containing false information.
Yeah Trump said, "There's plenty
more where that came from."
♪ Conan's speaking truth to power ♪
♪ Fighting for the little guys ♪
♪ Boldly goes where no one's gone ♪
♪ He called Trump a liar ♪
Wait, what was that?
Andy, trust me, this is
going to be huge, okay.
Okay.
Hey, yesterday Amazon's CEO Jeff Bezos
made $13 billion in one day, one day!
Yeah, it turns out a Whole Foods customer
bought one jar of almond butter.
♪ Watch the institutions crumble ♪
♪ Billionaires will bite the dust ♪
♪ Bezos' fortune is no match for ♪
♪ Conan's satire ♪
Conan, I've gotta be honest,
these jokes are kind of soft.
It doesn't matter about the jokes, okay.
It's how I present it with sex
appeal and 80's confidence.
In a speech yesterday Joe
Biden said that President Trump
is quote "Poisoning our democracy."
Biden also said his nurse is
stealing his credit cards.
♪ Did you see what Conan did there ♪
♪ What a clever thing to do ♪
♪ Though he'd zig but he just zagged ♪
♪ A real twisteroo ♪
What's a twisteroo?
Andy, I don't have time right now.
I'm busy selling these jokes
in a new and innovative way.
This week is the Kentucky Derby,
known as the fastest
two minutes in sports.
My wife said I'm more familiar
with the slowest two minutes.
♪ I think you know what Conan's saying ♪
♪ Do I have to spell it out ♪
♪ When it comes to making love ♪
♪ He's like a cold trout ♪
Yeah, I think we've heard
enough from that guy
singing a lukewarm hit from the 80's.
♪ Andy's got a real good point there ♪
♪ I don't known where things went wrong ♪
♪ Better get my ass to night school ♪
♪ And learn a new song ♪
All right, we have a great show tonight.
J. B. Smoove is gonna be joining us,
we'll be right back.
Andy, warm up the crowd
and keep them happy.
All right.
(upbeat music)